34 years to the day since her body was
discovered dumped in a ditch today
caroline pierce's killer was jailed for
life david fuller also killed and
sexually abused wendy nell in the same
year of 1987. both families had all but
given up hope of justice
we've been hoping and hoping and hoping
for years
and now it's just come and it's not
gonna sink in for a little while
but since his arrest last december david
fuller has become almost more notorious
for sexually assaulting over a hundred
dead women and girls in two kent
hospital mortuaries where he worked for
three decades
before sentencing families of the
victims talked of the devastating impact
the mother of a nine-year-old victim
said it will haunt me forever and the
rest of my life i will go home tonight
like every night and see the abuse that
that man has done to my baby that man
has taken everything from me
the father of a victim said fuller has
taken our little girl's innocence and
destroyed our souls i am consumed with
anger the daughter of a victim said you
have proved in your depravity that
monsters are very real you are the
absolute worst of humanity
john who doesn't want to be identified
spoke of his wife being violated by
fuller i looked at him and i said to him
when he gets put away in jail i hope he
has time to reflect on what he's done
and think himself lucky that he wasn't
going to be sharing a cell with me
despite being given two whole life
sentences for the murders the decades of
mortuary rapes only amounted to 12 years
so for example for raping the body of
azra kamal three times he was given just
three months this is the respect the
criminal justice system gives
the victims three months for each
offence
of rape
very painful i cannot heal
how can you heal
i can't find any other adjectives to
describe him describing the contempt i
have for him
because of the impact that we have that
it's had on those individuals and the
families but but the number of people
going to be impacted by it for the rest
of their lives with the memories of
their loved ones we're talking hundreds
if not thousands of people impacted by
it an inquiry has been set up to examine
how fuller got away with this for so
long but families want reassurances that
it will be robust and that sentencing
laws will be toughened
jason farrell sky news